kevin
okay no five
four three two one
and you're live chairman good afternoon
and welcome to this joint status
committee meeting on tuesday
the 27th october 2020 my name is
councillor michael helm and i am the
chairman of this committee
and your video feed is off when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbance
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate
if you wish to speak i will then invite
you at the appropriate time
members are in mind that apart from
indicating you wish to speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used
for questions or any other purpose
please do not raise your hand function
as this is not available on members
devices
when speaking referring to the agenda
papers please ensure you reference
a page and a paragraph number and last
if members need to leave the meeting at
any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function to signify that you need
to leave the meeting
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce yourself
starting mr crouch mr crouch
yes thank you chairman um good afternoon
simon quelch
and um i'm the lead legal specialist and
monitoring officer
good afternoon members brenda casey
clark to the committee
thank you any other officers present
no chairman can you please now carry out
the roll call of members to confirm who
is in attendance in attendance thank you
thank you members i will call your names
in alphabetical order please indicate
you're in attendance
starting with councillor bassinger
[Music]
good afternoon everyone yes i'm here
good afternoon berna
thank you very much cancer center
good afternoon everyone yes i'm present
and uh
hello and hello berna thank you council
helm
president jarvis
good afternoon better chairman members
thank you
councilmance
uh good afternoon bernard thank you
none yes good afternoon berna good
afternoon everyone
good afternoon cancer citadel yeah good
afternoon burner present
thank you councillor peter stilts
good afternoon everybody yes i'm here
thank you councillor thompson
good afternoon everyone yes i'm here
thank you thank you
thank you chairman can i now ask those
members in attendance to introduce
themselves please
who's that second person sorry oh cancer
cancer lagging
thank you thank you and of course
councillor morris
councilman thank you thank you very much
thank you chairman apologist for absence
please bernard
uh well yes we've received apologies
uh this is rather strange now apologies
for absolute cancer stamp and we've got
cancer syddle
substituting for a counsellor stamp and
that's because um now she's leader of
the opposition
even though she's a in attendance today
she cannot actually formally attend
the committee i hope that's
that makes sense thank you very much
it's part of the constitution
thank thank you
uh minutes for the last two meetings
held on the 3rd of september it's
recommended the minutes of the meeting
held on the 3rd of september found on
pages 5 to 20 are approved as true and
accurate record i sir move if you wish
to second that motion please turn on
your video
i'll mute your microphone and state your
name now please
counselor none seconded thank you
uh do we
is there no message uh accuracy matters
in this
at all uh yeah mr chairman um
counselor mays yes page
10 paragraph three um
thank you have you got that burner yes i
have thank you very much councillor mays
no worries right do we want to take a
vote on this or do we would do this by
saying
agreed agreed
right thank you very much for that
declaration of interest to close the
existence of any disposable
pecuniary interests or other peculiar
interests or non-pecuniary interests
relating the item business of the agenda
having regard to paragraph
628 inclusive of the code of conduct
members are reminding that
they are also required to disclose any
such interests
as soon as they became aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function
now to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
is there anybody berna councillor
thompson chairman
thompson thank you chairman um
yes i have a i'm not sure that it's uh
it's certainly not a pecuniary interest
and i don't think it's a
non-petunary interest but i certainly
have a conflict of interest in the
complaints part of the proceedings so i
shall be participating or voting thank
you
thank you for that anybody else casa
siddal
uh thank you chairman i'd like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest
in terms of the uh complaints part of
the process
uh because some of the complaints took
place
or were directed perhaps at me however
i don't think that compromises my
position in terms of
uh looking at those items
thank you for that council signal
anybody else
no chairman right we move on to it
oh sorry that's fine sorry chairman
carry on
committee on standards in public life
best practice recommendation simon
please
okay chairman uh thank you very much
chairman yeah um
this uh report really came about because
the committee um the government
committee
was set up by the government on
publix on standards in public life sent
out as you'll see
a letter to all councils
um sending out its best practice
recommendations that it had produced in
a report in in
in 2019 and you can see
my appendix one is the letter from the
committee on standards in public life
and that sets out 15
best practice recommendations that are
relevant to the council relevant to the
joint standards committee
and what they want to do is they they
would like a response
from the council in relation to
whether they accept those best practice
recommendations now there's no
legal obligation on the council to
respond to them they are only a
committee
set up by the government but um
obviously when i got that letter i
brought this matter to the committee
um obviously it's good benchmarking to
see how
our own practices go how the council's
practices go so
you will see in my appendix 2
um page 27 you will see that i've set
out each of the best practice
recommendations
in ordinary type and then
my response in italics under each one
um uh chairman would you like me to go
through them one by one
i think so best for everybody i think
okay
well best practice one says that local
authorities should include prohibitions
on bullying and harassment in codes of
conduct
that include a definition of bullying
and harassment
supplemented with a list of examples of
the sort of behavior
covered by such a definition you can see
that i've
put in a definition it very much f the
harassment bit very much
focuses on the equality act and
the protected characteristics the
bullying
is much wider and then i put in some
examples now the definition comes from a
cat so it's not my work
um and the examples also are provided by
by a cass as well
and what i'm suggesting is that um
this definition of bullying and
harassment is not
entered into the code of conduct itself
but is put as a footnote in which case
it doesn't really require full
council to to to agree the amendment
you would only need four counts so you
can only make a recommendation on the
revision of the code full council makes
the decision on that but as this is
purely clarification on what those
i believe this committee can do that if
it wants to
so this would be a footnote um
in the code of conduct
should i stop their chairman for for any
members to uh
chairman for youtube members like to ask
some questions please
yes counselor nun and cancer channel
counselor none counsel first and then
counselor channel
thank you very much chairman and thank
you simon for your introduction to that
um uh i feel personally chairman
that we would be very foolish as a
council
if we did not take notice of this and if
we did not adopt these principles
um however i was very pleased
to read through the document and through
mr quelch's commentary
because i thought personally that
actually we cover most of those things
already
in our code
but i was particularly pleased to see
reference to
bullying and harassment however of
course there is a world of difference
between
a written policy of any kind and its
actual application in practice
um and um that
i think is is the the crux of the matter
here
and that that's where we turn full
circle of course because
some of these issues end up coming to
this committee
um but um i for one uh
don't mind going on record and saying
that i am fed up
with the volume and nature
of these complaints that we're receiving
and i very much hope that we can move to
more
stable and harmonious times uh in the
future
thank you very much chair it's not a
question it's just a statement thank you
very much for that council not much
appreciated
um we've got councillor channel first
and then i've got some with the red
jumper
peter stilts i've got you now because i
couldn't see your head
thank you chairman chairman do you want
me to speak now
yes please thank you chairman um
when i say i'm going to declare an
interest the only reason i will
um i'm just thinking about it um is
because i sat on a committee at essex
county council
in relatively recent times where this
very same document
came forward and essex county council
did respond to that
and i was involved i guess in some of
the decision making
so i feel it better perhaps not to i
would though make a comment chairman it
is to do with bullying and harassment
and just to say and highlight um and
perhaps mr
crouch could just ask this so i won't
vote but just ask the question
regarding bullying bullying doesn't have
to be repetitive
bullying can only be actually one
particular event uh it could be a threat
or you take to perceive something as a
threat and then
that might be then denied by someone
who's made a threat or other things like
that or words
intimidation various things and
uh therefore chairman if mr crouch could
answer that it doesn't have to be
repetitive
it can be one incident that you might
take a front to and that's all i will
say chairman having um
actually um legal engagement in in
relatively recent times thank you thank
you
peter stilts please can mr crowd
respond yes sorry yeah um uh
i i i agree with uh councillor mrs
channer
a one-off is enough although normally
with bullying you see a
continuation but counselor mrs chana is
right
it can be a one-off one and i think
what's particularly relevant chairman if
i might
bring in something particularly
following on from something
um sort of adding on to my own
explanation of what that counselor nun
said
if you see the examples of bullying
they are one-offs as counselor mrs chan
has said but they
often are a continuous pattern and
you'll see also one of them which is
very relevant to this council
is the second line of the examples when
copying memos that are critical about
someone to others
who do not need to know
ridicule or demeaning someone so
and that's very relevant sometimes to
the practices of some members
who copy in everybody about a particular
member or particular
complaint and this is described by acas
as an example
of bullying or harassment
so these are not my examples they are a
cass's examples
perhaps chairman i could just say one
other thing not not so much in response
to
um councilman mrs chana's question but i
ought to have mentioned this at the
beginning
that um i forgot to mention it
is that the local government association
are in the process
of drafting a new model code of conduct
and uh the latest i've heard and i heard
it this
only the end of last week is that they
are proposing
to issue a new draft at the end of this
year
so some authorities may feel making
revisions or additions to their own old
code is premature
i don't quite share that view simply
because
um we don't actually know for sure
whether that code is going to come out
these things tend to take longer
than um they uh than we think
and also it may well be that the uh new
code is something this particular
council doesn't want to adopt anyway
uh but i just mentioned that to chairman
as something i should have mentioned at
the beginning
thank you very much peter i believe you
wanted to peter stilts with it
i believe sorry
regarding what mr crutch just said i
think the last thing is best
if we get in now we've got it there and
it may actually prove to be a guide
to the authority that's doing their code
they may look at it and say oh that's
something good
right now back to this um who is this
for is it for the staff
employees or for councillors because i'm
not quite sure because
um we're under code of conduct and
they're under
employment etc but does it cover
everybody across the thing
um and i believe it says in the document
it should be the bottom
it's got to be in the document um and
definition
uh as what is considered to be bullying
has to be stated
um there's no doubt as to whether
someone's doing wrong or not otherwise
it could be held in defense
that what the council considers bullying
is not properly defined and therefore
being unacceptable
that's it thanks simon would you like to
answer that
please just dealing with that second
point first i
i agree with um uh councillor uh stilts
yeah i mean i think that's right if
you've got a definition then that makes
it easier for the standards committee
when it comes to make a decision it's
got an objective standard with example
so i i agree with that
the the second point is this this is
this definition
only applies to the local code of
conduct this whole paper
is to do with the members code of
conduct and doesn't apply to the
employees code of conduct
that suffice mr chairman yes um so what
happens if we get from
employee to counsel or the other way
around which is unfortunately more
likely to happen
um how does cross-reference happen
without them
simon obviously if an
employee makes a complaint against the
councillor that will be under the local
code of conduct
so if if the committee agree this
for example point the definition of
bullying and harassment then that that's
what the committee would have in front
of it
in relation to uh a counsellor
uh making a complaint against an
employee that will depend on
obviously the what's in the employee's
code of conduct and i'm
i'm not aware of the detail of that i
would suspect there is a definition of
sorts
um in relation to bullying and
harassment because that would be
in the employee code of conduct but
there may be variations on that
okay because there are two different
codes there are two different code
um the employees code of conda obviously
will be outward facing to some extent
but primarily it's very much
inward facing conduct of employees
within the organization how they relate
to their colleagues how they relate
to stakeholders etc whereas this is very
much
it's it's designed to be much more
outward-facing although most of our
complaints are from counsellor a
counselor against counsellor
but it's meant to be much more outward
facing in the sense of
um the public that members are serving
although obviously includes internal as
well thank you
norma
uh yeah thank you mr chairman um can i
just have a bit of clarity on this
um are we looking at adopting these and
uh incorporating these best practices
in our current uh code of conduct uh
in addition to a response to
the um letter that mr clark
has already had can you just clarify
that for me please
simon the answer is yes and yes
um okay i just wanted to make sure that
i'd understood this correctly
yeah no i thought i thought well what
i'm suggesting in my report is that
we make any neces the committee make any
changes
like on this best practice one here and
now and then we can respond
uh to the committee the government
committee saying
um we agree with you and we've done it
okay thank you council thompson
thank you chairman um a question through
you please probably to
mr quilt um i'm assuming that these
um these standards apply across the
board
and would not be expected to be
varied according to well according to
the council or according to one's normal
demeanor or style i presume
that the standard of expose standard of
behavior expected is
absolute thank you
if we're looking at best practice one
for example um the examples of bullying
and harassment yes they are not
subjective and i think that's the point
that council stilts the good point that
council stilts was making
that you need an objective standard
when you come to to make a decision on
bullying and harassment obviously you
will take account of the feelings of the
person that is the victim as well
we know in today's world that's very
relevant how does the person feel
themselves
but you still need this objective
standard
so yes this this is objective rather
than subjective
thank you simon is anybody else did
cancer thompson want to come back sorry
no sorry i was just saying thank you
thank you chairman okay uh
counselor please
thank you chairman uh are we gonna my
first question is are we going through
each of these best practices
uh one at a time or are we discussing uh
the whole
is my first question well simon's been
through the whole lot i believe
and it's not we've only talked about
best practice one okay
simon what do you want to do well i
think chairman i asked you should i go
through
um each one one by one and i think you
felt that was a good idea
um so i i i'm still on best practice one
i'm in your hands chairman if you
if you would like to do it globally i
can do that and just let members
ask questions of me on all the matters
that might be quicker
on the other hand if you want to be more
thorough i can go through it one by one
so i'm in your hands chairman
what would you prefer counselor i'd
prefer going through one by one
so on best practice one uh say mr quelch
yeah i think yeah this is a very
important
uh definition to put into our code of
conduct
however if we are going to put it into
the code of conduct for
members it does need to be
perhaps modified so it reflects a
member's role
because some of this is sort of employee
related
so i don't know whether we can
alter it slightly so that it becomes
more orientated
towards a member's role excuse me the
other thing is as well
is in terms of a member
we as we've discovered part of being a
member part of being a politician
is to have to deal with rough and tumble
as it were
and verbal rough and humble of the
situation
so yeah bullying could be a one of event
but my view in terms of of a member's
role is it's more likely
to be something that is more ongoing
uh in terms of a behavior between
members or a member to an officer
perhaps
which is slightly different to have
perhaps an employee situation so that's
that's many of my comments
any more question
on best practice one night german
councilor thompson would like to make a
suggestion
i um
it was only on a question of process
chairman thanks i wondered if if members
would actually like to do this by
exception and
talk about the ones they want to talk
about specifically rather than every
single one but
it's just a thought thank you is that
proposal
oh well no not as such um
it was just a case of um not spending
time reading stuff out if everyone's
already happy with it
thank you members what would you like to
do
um no mr chairman uh councillor mays i
think we should continue
and do do do due diligence on this
um furthermore i really feel that the
recommendations from here should go to
full council
for full consideration by everybody
thank you
uh german counselor channel would like
to come back on this please cancel the
channel please
uh thank you chairman so i couldn't see
to get myself i'm muted
uh thank you very much um just to say
respect councillor citizen's view but um
i do appreciate members need to be in
the rough and tumble
but i would say that actually a one-off
event
for a counsellor can be very much a real
issue in terms of bullying
harassment intimidation and matters you
might perceive as
a threat and i don't want to go into
details how i know i can substantiate
that
um but um i know that i can
um how do i get out i'm mr chairman
yes i'd like to come back um to that
um my in my particular case having sat
in the council chamber
i was my complaint was actually ignored
and i felt
extremely harassed um and i was very
distressed at the bullying that took
part it was a one-off
as the um councillor chana said
um and i would agree totally with her
position on that
okay so uh we're going to run through
the rest or we're going to do members
counseling did have a proposal i don't
know whether he'd like to come back
i don't know whether it was about the
process or going forward
uh well it was uh thank you um
i i opened my remarks by saying that
we'd be foolish not to include
the um proposals from uh the document
that
uh mr quilt should uh been through with
us and i
i think we ought to look at adopting
those
amendments and additions to be quite
honest with you
i mean that none of them are that
earth-shattering compared with what
we've already got
they're just they're just beefing it up
and as far as harassment and bullying is
concerned
uh my views on that as an ex hr manager
is that it's the way that it's received
and perceived by the
individual and it can either be a
one-off incident or it can be a series
of incidents
so i don't know why while we're
troubling ourselves there
it can be once or it can be a program of
of issues
agreed is that a proposal then chairman
hold on right here the recommendation to
say the report as follows to consider
appendix to
make any necessary managed accounts
which i think we've already done
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video i'll
move your microphone
and state your name now
happy to second chairman thompson thank
you
do we want to do this by a cent or do we
want to do an injury draw
no this needs to be a vote but it should
also go to full council mr chairman
well the report will go to full council
chairman can i just say council of civil
would like to speak
please
cancer yes thank you thank you chairman
uh well as we are now rushing this uh so
i'd like to look at
best practice eight please so
in terms of that the independent person
should be consulted as to whether to
take forward an informal investigation
now
we know that uh in terms of our
constitution in terms of our process in
the summer
the constitution was not covered
properly
in terms of best practice eight when a
report came back to
council however it wasn't our monitoring
officer
it was a monitoring officer from another
council was appointed in terms of that
investigation
now at that particular time i did a lot
of research
and investigation into our constitution
and process
and also the constitutional process for
the other council
and when you look at our constitution
for our
and and download it it's a complete and
utter mess
in terms of the process so there are
lots of amendments
lots of changes lots of different colors
so trying to follow it
yes there's lots of track changes to
that document so
one thing i would suggest in terms of
best practice eight
is that our procedure and our
constitution for joint standards
is tidied up so that when you read it
it's clear and understandable because at
the moment
i don't think it is thank you
simon your comments please
okay um this
this the the procedure was was
agreed by council as i understand this
was before my time
i think it was a little bit before i
came in september 2017
um i personally have no
difficulty following it um
i consulted all the time whenever an
investigation comes in
um in terms of best practice eight
um i'm sure mr hudson will confirm this
or or not confirm it but i constantly am
in contact with him whenever there is an
investigation
and um at the very beginning
as to what's done with
the uh complaint
i am in touch with him and when i look
at the
procedure note in it's article
seven it's it's it's in the articles of
the constitution
and it's it's number seven um i'm
i'm clear in my own mind what it means
but that may be to be fair to counselor
siddal simply because i've used it
on on arguably too many occasions i've
had to go through it so i'm familiar
with it
and maybe someone reading for the first
time
i don't think it is simple i agree with
that i don't think it's a simple
procedure
um but i think if you study it it is
clear
and the reason it's not simple is
because there are a number of
alternatives
um and i think trying to simplify it
would be very
difficult so can i come back please
yes you may yeah so i'm not asking you
to sympathize it
uh simon um uh yeah when one of the
things that
yeah and we had a discussion and i had
lots of discussions at that particular
time with with you and the other
monitoring officer
and uh the directors of of the council
and
yeah when you look at that particular
part which is stage two of the process
where the independent person is
consulted
in terms of the next step there
it's not clear as to what the next step
would be
and we had the situation in the summer
where we had that next step
and according to my understanding the
next step
in terms of that process is the report
comes to the joint standards committee
now in that particular situation
it didn't so somewhere along the line
the process has not been followed and
and therefore
to me there is a question about when
that independence person is spoken to at
stage two
where that particular process goes to so
that's that's my query
simon chairman yeah um okay
and we're dealing with obviously
specific case now i'll deal with that
specific case then as an example
of of the process um
counselor civil's right i wasn't
involved um at that particular point
there was a an outside monitoring
officer from castle point who was
handling the matter
and i for for because i was a
part of the i was interviewed by the
investigator i had to stand
completely away from it and i did so
the the process as i understand it the
procedure as i understand it
is that when a report
is completed
it can either come it can either
go to the standards committee or the
monitoring officer
in consultation with the independent
person
can still based on the recommendations
of the investigating officer can still
opt for an informal resolution
rather than putting it to this joint
standards committee
for a decision on whether there's been a
breach
and if so what sanction if any to impose
so my understanding is in that
particular case the procedure was
followed because
the monitoring officer from castle point
consulted
um mr anthony as i understand it he was
standing in as a reserve
and they both agreed that a informal
solution should be imposed which is what
they did
now i believe that was quite within the
uh wording of the procedure document
okay so my view so my again if you look
at the procedure and you look at that so
i'm just trying to get this cleared up
so it never happens again
okay um when there is an informal
resolution
the complainants should be spoken to
and that they are happy that an
employment an informal resolution
is the right approach in the situation
the complainants were not consulted
in terms of that informal resolution so
that so
and that was my big issue at the time
and i don't want to go over that and
spend lots of times on it
but that bit didn't happen and that's
the crucial bit that i
yeah that that's really important that
if we if
we do raise the complaint and and
something where where the judgment
is that they those members did bring the
council into disrepute
and and then we don't have the
complainants consulted
it's that that's bad yeah and that's
that needs tightening up there needs to
be something that says
if there is an informal resolution do
the complainants get consulted that they
agree to that because it didn't happen
well hang
yes good afternoon councillors um i
think you're going to go around in
circles here this afternoon to be honest
i think you've got a document in front
of you councillors
in fact i i was slightly involved with
the essex county council review
and i would propose to you guys and you
need to digest this that um
that individual counsellors make
their representations to simon and simon
digest the document
and recirculate recirculates it to you
for approval
otherwise you're going to go around in
circles this afternoon get nowhere in my
opinion
thank you thank you very much that i i
will give i will give way
and i've made my point okay and i i
don't want to
i don't want to bang on about it okay
did you want to say anything more
yeah i think i think councillor still
makes an important point that probably
does
merit a clarification for all members on
the committee about the
process i know that's not part exactly
of
best practice eight although it's linked
to it um
and that is that
in the pres in the um procedure
agreed by council for dealing with
complaints there is nothing in that
in it about going back to complainants
and you wouldn't expect that to be in my
view
because the investigation process
will normally involve the investigator
in speaking to the complainants
and addressing how they felt about the
particular incident
what their expectations are from the
investigation
and then for a monitoring officer to go
back
and then say to the complainers well i'm
thinking of doing
a b and c are you happy with that
really is almost another part of an
investigation that has already taken
place
if the investigators done his or her job
then they will be they will have spoken
to the complainants
and they will have understood those
particular issues
i think it complicates it if the
monitoring officer then has to go back
to the complainants and say
well what do you think okay
so to one of theo's ass simon is is when
you look at code of conducts
the constitution for different types of
joint status investigations
it is it does vary from malden district
council to castle point borough council
for example
so the two two are are different yeah
and
the monitoring officer from castle point
borough council it does say that
at that particular point after
consulting that you go back to
complainants
it doesn't say that on the modern
district council one so so therefore
that's why
i had that big query about it all about
where do we go at that particular stage
in stage two
but that's all i want to say all right
shall we now move on
no german councilman councillor mays
councillor thompson councillor nunn and
councillor jarvis would like to speak
start in that order then please please
thank you mr chairman um really on from
um councillor fiddle um i agree with his
position
um i also think that um if
we are sending a um investigation
outside we should make it very clear
where the uh report comes back
to um and because um it was such a
serious
uh situation in the example that was
quoted
that should have come back to a jsc if
we are not
think uh believing that predetermination
is a serious um code of conduct breach
then we are very mistaken further
um and my other point um relates to can
we please go back to best practice three
or two or wherever we've got to because
we're now going to start to jump all
over the place
and we're going to lose track of what
we're doing
thank you
who was else then please counselor
thompson counselor nun
and councillor jarvis thompson please
thank you chairman um presumably the
if if an outside investigator takes over
whether they're
a monitoring officer officer elsewhere
or whatever
then they're going to follow our code of
conduct
and its processes not not some other one
um that would be silly um i was actually
going to echo
mr hodgson's suggestion that we come
back with our ideas
to mr quelch but um apparently we're
about to go through one by one but we do
need to bear in mind members that we can
only recommend to council and we can
obviously debate it there and there'll
be a report there thanks chairman
cast a nun please
thank you very much chair um i mean i
understand why
the conversation is going the way it's
going
but instead of reviewing the words of
the procedure
we are doing what i said at the start of
this meeting
which is actually we're looking at its
application
and that's not what we're being asked to
do with this agenda
item this agenda item is about reviewing
the document in line with the words uh
from the standards in public life and
um i i come back to the point that we
would be
foolish as a council not to adopt those
amendments and changes now i've got a
seconded proposal on the table chairman
i'm happy to withdraw that proposal
in favor of mr hodgson's suggestion
if it would suit um other members that
mr quelch tidies up the document with
the amendments
gets it round to all of the members here
we say whether we're happy with it or
make any changes and then
we we um endorse it to go to full
council
thank you very much to the council was
there anybody else after that
uh yes chairman council jarvis pastor
jarvis
if he's dropped cancer jarvis he's just
hold on
just bear with me caster jarvis are you
back with us
i've just admitted yeah apologies there
i think i must
i must have pressed the wrong button um
sharon yes
just on the second point that council
had none mentioned
firstly um that sounds like a jolly good
idea which i think was
mr hudson's idea that perhaps we take a
bit longer
to go through these points and go back
in more detail on them so i sort of
endorse that
but i did just want to without wishing
to prolong
the discussion unnecessarily if it's not
on the agenda
i just wanted to comment on councillor
civil's point because i do feel it's
really very important and i'm not sure
um
that some questions given what i
consider to be a clear answer on that
i can quite understand that there will
be circumstances whereby
uh it might be appropriate to
deal with the matter without going to
jsc um but that would have to be in a
situation
where clearly perhaps there wasn't a
serious offence
it was sound to me and i'm not surprised
to hear that other councils have come
across this issue and got it written
into their code
that um there would be some consultation
with those people
who've made the complaints because it
would not be a serious issue the people
making complaints might say
well that's fine well i'm happy if it's
going to be dealt with like that
but you can't have a situation where
we're
silent on the matter where you could
have a situation that might be a very
serious complaint
that then doesn't come to jsc because
that means that joint standards
committee
um aren't in the sort of right running
order it seems to me
um so i would have thought i'm not happy
about the way that
situa that decision was made i think
either it automatically has to come
to join standards or the complainants
are given the opportunity
to say yeah we're we're happy that it's
been dealt with effectively in which
case
you know it would probably be not a
serious offence so i'm not happy that
that sounds to me like
unfinished business and i think i would
like to ask
simon quelsch to review that part of our
code and to cons to review what other
councils do
if they've come across this issue and
they've bottomed it out
and that we adopt something that's
really clear because i know that an
awful lot of councillors
felt that that report should have come
to joint standards committee
they were told it was going to come to
joint standards committee
and at the last minute it seemed to get
pulled and some offenses which were
clearly described as very serious
then got re-badged as not really you
know sort of the lowest possible sort of
complaint
i'm not happy how that was dealt with
but that's historical
but let's ensure that it doesn't happen
again which is council the civil's point
and so let's ask i would ask councillors
to ask
the committee to ask simon quelch to go
away and add something
in that part of the code so that this
doesn't occur again
thank you chad anyone here from simon
cross please through you chairman
simon yeah i think i make my view very
clear councillor jarvis on that point
um i think it's duplication and
complication
if you have a provision in the process
that requires on every occasion the
monitoring officer to go back
to complainants for example let's just
say there was in that
what about ifs joint standards committee
should they have to go back
to complainants can i can i make a point
of clarification chairman
we're talking about not a situation
where it's going to go to joint
standards committee obviously that would
be a complete duplication a waste of
time
we're talking about a situation where
some could be
some could make the accusation that it
looked like it was being
tucked under the carpet where an
informal decision was going to be made
now in those situations i agree there
might be a scenario where
it is the right thing that we don't take
it to jersey but the caveat would be
that it would be an informal decision
informal implies that it's not a very
major offense
therefore in those situations the
complainants must have the opportunity
to be involved in the process as they
clearly do in other councils
perhaps i could bring in another
dimension chairman please simon
um that one of the things that's that's
lacking
in a lot of other processes where
complaints
are made is that you have someone that
administers the complaint system or an
investigating officer
and then it might go to another body to
make a decision
but the localism act has introduced a
very important person into the process
that isn't in normally other complaints
process and that's
the independent person and
this is really where the independent
person would come in
where report is completed
then the next stage according to our
process is that the monitoring officer
then has to consult
with the independent person about the
contents of the report and whether that
should go
to jsc or whether it should be dealt
with
informally and this is really where you
could say you're going to get a very
objective neutral view because the
independent person is very much treated
by the government and you'll probably
see in these recommendations and if you
consider the report of the committee on
public standards the independent person
is a
very important person and the localism
act focuses on the importance of the
independent person
so i would um my view would be
that that is where your control is if
you have a sort of a monitoring officer
that because he's an employee or she's
an employee
they they have a particular bias
we all as human beings have biases
then the independent person can step in
and say no that's not the way to go with
that
okay we'll see you chairman i'll just
make one final comment if i may
i considered some of those offenses that
were that sort of
were committed to being very serious in
my opinion
and yet it got dealt with in an informal
manner and was then rebadged on a number
of occasions by various councillors as
the lowest possible offence that was the
net result of the way that was handled
again i repeat i think it should have
come to jsc or i think complainant
should have been consulted
not to have a system that copes with one
or other of those
i think is deficient thank you jen
right bernard was there anybody else yes
chairman councillors channel and then
councilman
mays chester channel please oh thank you
chairman i am here
um i'm sorry here chairman if i'm going
to appear a party pooper now
no the agenda item is about the document
that mr quelch has received
and the intended response is to be given
back to that body
we're hearing the way forward from the
independent person
which sounds very sensible to me mr
quelch can make some of the amendments
he may have heard today send it round to
all of us
we then go back to mr quelch with our
respective views and we can then see the
finished document with those
implica um implied or put in that is
what essex county council did
the issue now we're on chem with all due
respect and you know i can understand
where people's feelings are on this may
be we're now really getting to the
specifics that came up perhaps in an
individual case
and we're now talking about that we need
to be adopting things that this
article has highlighted and put into our
uh council this this committee chairman
hundreds terms of reference does have
the right to advise the council and
local councils
on the adoption or revision of the um
the applicable member code of conduct
now i'm thinking chairman that needs to
be for another meeting that can be for
the chairman of this committee
to put that in the gender item and that
i feel is the correct place
for these suggestions that are now
coming forward because to me
they are not actually to do with the
matter of the agenda item
it's triggered the thinking and i
respect that but i don't think this is
the vehicle
that we should be making recommendations
to council on
as a result of our responses to this
body i mean they what they come back
within the autumn or whenever they're
going to come back with something is
another matter
i think there's two separate issues
being debated here chairman
and really i i propose chairman that we
uh
do follow uh mr hudson's suggestion
um that mr quelch applies some of the
amendments we're talking about circulate
to all members we go back with our views
and then the um document the responses
to the body that's approaches goes back
as for the issue of the other matters
which council of jarvis council is
signal and some other members may feel
uh needs to be uh the council adopts or
reviews
uh the code of conduct or the process um
or whatever
then with all due respect i think that
needs to be a separate agenda item at
another meeting and do a vision of the
code of conduct and processes or
whatever at that time chairman
sorry about that but um sorry to be a
party pooper
thank you very much for that well i
don't know if we've got one more because
i think we really need to move to get
this uh moved on
um i i believe constant did castermays
have something else to say
no that's the last comment yeah oh sorry
sorry bernard i
did through the chair um actually i
would totally agree with uh councillor
chana
um and and support support that view
thank you yes and cancer jobs is already
secondary cancer in china but
not you should not put in the meeting
chat and
thank you all for that we'll move on and
get simon to uh
amend and whatever and send it out to us
and then we can go forward so so
chairman sorry can we be clear
because the original recommendation in
the paperwork was to
um recommend council so regarding
appendix too so we're actually going
forward
now with cancer well cancer nun said the
exact same thing so
yeah we're taking it as a counselor
channel's proposal or counselor nuns
proposal
seconded by councillor jarvis yes that's
right both of them
because both proposals were the same
pressure match yes
yeah well i'd just like to be clear if i
may i was second in council
channel's proposal that the issue i
spoke on
a moment ago came to a future meeting
that was the proposal i was second
um yes as i said chairman if it moves
forward i'm happy to withdraw my
original proposal but i don't think
we're a million miles apart
it's about it's about simon beefing the
document up rewriting it getting it out
to everybody
we can comment on it uh and then it can
go to full council but we can have an
item on a future agenda to discuss
the issues in hand that's right yeah but
chairman when i made my because i'm
talking about under our terms of
reference
advising the council and local councils
on the adoption or revision of the
applicable member code of conduct or
processes so
i'm not just centering on that one issue
it may be there's other matters that
other
members of the committee might have they
want to raise it's just i felt we were
beginning to mix
two different things into this meeting
yes
yes i agree
right can we do this by a cent or do you
want to uh
go to the vote a record vote please
record it vote then please
we're no longer looking
at the recommendation as set out in the
report which was to consider appendix 2
i suppose it's pretty much the same
thing and make any necessary
recommendation to counsel
we're now slightly amending it going
with counsellor
nuns proposal if you could repeat that
please before we go to the vote
that would be really helpful
the chair thank you so my proposal
um is this then that um we would
we we as a as a as a committee
wish to adopt uh the suggested changes
we ask uh mr quelch to
um revise the document distribute it to
all members here
for comment uh and then we bring it back
to committee and take it to full council
but we have a separate
um agenda item next time to discuss the
matters in hand
thank you very much sorry chairman i'm a
bit confused
now i thought we were going to look at
the document oh sorry mr crouch was
going to look at the document amend it
send it around to all members we would
pass our comments back we might see it
but get it onto council does it need to
come back again
to this committee because that's a delay
um i just put on that on the table
and again i reiterate my proposal i'm
talking about the terms of reference
not just the matter that seemed to have
come up with it with a particular case
but to look at revision or processes and
other things there could be other
matters
members want to raise so that would be
the chairman's um
prerogative to bring that back and for
um a discussion on our
you know the code of conduct etc and
processes
but i think mr answered it actually but
i'm just trying to move things forward
and we're getting too
muddled i feel i am in two separate
issues
professor thompson did you want to say
something before we move
oh yeah i did please chairman
lots of discussions and it is this
council and unsaid mostly about
application of these rules
i haven't actually heard i don't think
any members suggest that
the list of best practices
recommendations needs to be amended so
i can't we just agree the recommendation
send it to council and all our thoughts
can go there
and so i'm happy the council of nuns
proposal the other
issues are side issues and they should
be dealt with in another meeting
because that isn't talking about best
practice
you know and i've got one or two
thoughts on that myself about always
getting the complainant to prove
because that hasn't always worked in the
past so that's a whole different matter
if you come to a different
meeting thank you chairman would you
permit me
um just to um yes please because we're
getting stuck here
um yeah i'm a little bit confused about
what the committee
are proposing that i do i have to say
um i think just as councillor thompson
said i'm not aware of any
amendments that the committee have made
to appendix
ii um particularly other than i think
councillor siddal mentioned that it
should be
um the definition was i'm not sure if it
was council but someone um
one members talked about it was council
yeah um should that we should make it
more
counsellor-based rather than
employee-based and that i probably need
to look at that
a bit more carefully i think that's the
only amendment that i've heard a member
suggest
so i'm i'm not sure if if if i if i
to use the words beef it up i'm not sure
in what way i'd beef it up
other than doing what council said
right where are we now then
peter now um norman is that norman
in the red sorry that's peter stilts
sorry i can't quite see your head carry
on
i must be growing no i've got a big sign
over the top of you that's some trouble
oh i see right i'm not a member
of morgan district council so will i be
allowed to speak
if it goes before commit full council uh
as i am here
um because i've got previous life
board of inquiries i was doing um there
are tweaking
on i've got three four six
seven and there's some more as well
they're minor points but
uh they're more for best practice
so if simon prints everything out is
then going to come out i'm going to say
excuse me can we change that this should
be changed under press
best practice so what are we going to do
well i'm in your hands members let's
hear it
report here too i'll come
thank you chairman yeah um counselor
nuns put a proposal on the table
i felt which sounded quite sensible um
so we would get the opportunity to uh
look at this further and go back with
further comments to some questions then
might be incorporated and it would come
back to committee before it went to
council i felt in circumstances that
seemed a reasonable
suggestion and
i think that seconded i think we should
vote on that
we vote on that please um
yes chairman members we're going to vote
on councillor nun's proposal which has
been seconded by councillor mays and i'm
going to take a recorded vote
i'll call your names in alphabetical
order please indicate
four against our abstain starting with
councillor bassinger
four
uh sorry about that just had to get
unmuted i did say at the beginning that
i wasn't going to vote
um on the matter of the form
because of the answers but what this is
now this is about a proposal about
being uh the document coming back
amended and coming back so i feel i can
because i'm not clear totally on what
the amendments might be
so i'm not voting um i can feel i can
vote if you can see where i'm coming
from because we actually haven't decided
to forward this document on yet so
i'll say four
thank you cancer helm for
caster jarvis
four master maze
this committee i thought he proposed it
went to council but i'll say four anyway
because
that sounds fine to me either way
did customer want to clarify that i
think he did suggest coming back to the
committee and then
i did
okay members that's eight for none
against no abstentions thank you
chairman
thank you very much members right item
number six
any items of business that the chairman
of the committee decides are urgent
members i have an item to consider is
urgent and i
consider should be determined at this
meeting it relates to a complaint by a
council against himself
and another councillor the two
complaints are connected
all members will have seen the two
complaints because the
complainant not only emailed the
monitoring officer
all members i believe they should be
dealt with as a private and confidential
matter
following consideration of the existing
report at item eight
with that in mind i now move to item
agenda seven
to include this urgent item under the
resolution
that the public and press are excluded
from under paragraph 1
and 6b to schedule 12a the local
government act
1972. i i second that chairman
thank you everyone in agreement
agreeing right to resolve that under
section 100a iv of the local government
act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that they
involve
the likely disclosure of exempt
information is defined in paragraph
1 and 6b of part 1 of the scheduled 12a
to the act
and that this satisfies the public
interest test and i will now ask
committee service to end the live
public screen to the public along with
the recording of the meeting
and i'll ask any non-committee members
not in in attendance to now leave and
members of the public
thank you